or on problem 84 on a company sponsored
cruise 2/3 of the passengers were
company employees and the remaining
passengers were their guests
so we could say employees is equal to
2/3 of passengers and I guess we could
also say that guests are equal to 1/3 of
passengers right the remainder are
guests if 3/4 of the company employee
passengers were managers what was the
number of company employee passengers
who were not managers ok so statement
the second statement in the least the
problem statement it says if 3/4 of of
let's see if 3/4 of the company employee
passengers were managers it's a company
employee passenger so 3/4 of E were
managers if I read that statement if 3/4
of the company employee passengers or
managers what was the number of company
employee passengers who were not
managers so we essentially so what
percentage so essentially they want to
know what 1/4 of E is right this is what
they're asking because they want to know
what were the number of company employee
passengers that were not managers in
that 3/4 were managers 1/4 were not
managers so if we could figure out P we
would be able to figure out e and we'd
be able to figure out 1/4 e if we were
able to figure out guests we could then
use that to figure out P which we could
use to figure out a which we could then
figure out 1/4 e so that's how we should
be thinking about it now that we should
be spending that much time on it problem
number 1 there were 600 90 passengers
690 is equal to P well that we'd be done
right because E is equal to 2/3 P and we
want to know what 1/4 e is so then our
answer is so the non manager employees
would be 1/4 times e which is just 2/3
times P
time's 690 and that would be our answer
so one alone is sufficient and the
statement number two there were 230
passengers who were guests of the
company employees so they're saying
essentially saying that guests are equal
two guests are equal to 230 and we could
use this information that guests are
just one third of P so which is equal to
one third of P and then of course from
there you could solve you could multiply
three times both sides equation to
figure out that C is equal to SiC P is
equal to six ninety six ninety which is
so this is the same information that
they gave in one which was enough to
solve the problem so two alone is also
sufficient so they are each
independently sufficient to solve the
problem that problems confusing just
with the language company employee
manager passenger guests it was very
confusing 85 in the XY plane does the
point 4 comma 12 lie on line K okay this
is interesting so let's let me draw a
line okay and I'll worry about the point
4 comma 12 later so let's see they say
let me look at the points that they do
say is line K so they let me so if this
is the x-axis that's the y-axis
statement 1 tells us that the point 1 7
lies on case of the point 1 comma 7 lies
on K 1 comma 7 and then they also tell
us that the point well you know that
alone isn't going to let me know if the
point 4 comma 12 lies on it so 1 2 3 4 4
comma 12 it might be up here right this
is the point that we care about if you
can see that let me scroll down 4 comma
12 so if the line looks like that maybe
we'd go goes through but the line could
be like that's the statement number 1
alone isn't enough statement number 2
says the point minus 2 comma 2 so minus
2 minus 2 comma minus 2 X is minus 2 y
is positive 2 you
so they're saying that lies on it
eyeballing it it seems - - comma -
eyeballing this line K it seems like 4
comma 12 could very well lie on it but
we have to do a little bit of math to
figure it out so first of all just
statement or two by itself doesn't help
us cuz this line could go anywhere you
need two points to just know what the
line is and so how do we figure out if
the point 4 comma 12 is on this line
well the easiest way to do it is to
figure out the slope well I don't know
if it's the easiest way but it's the way
I would think about doing it is to
figure out the slope of the line and
then extend that slope here and see if
the point 4 comma 12 lies on it so let's
see what's the slope of this line so
when we went up 7 - 2 so the rise is 5
when you go up 5 we went over how much 1
minus -2 we went over 3 right so for
every 3 that you move over you go up 5
that's the easiest way to think about it
so when we go from we're going from X is
equal to 1 to X is equal to 4 so we're
going to the right by 3 and so we should
be going up 5 so 5 + 7 sure enough is
equal to 12
so these so if you just extend the slope
it does hit the point 4 comma 12 so both
statements combined are well actually
you know what I just wasted a lot of
your time because we just have to know
whether the data is sufficient to answer
the question we don't have to prove that
the question is true I've just proven to
you that that 4 comma 12 does lie on the
line but you could have just said oh
well you know what statement number 1
gives me a point on the line that alone
isn't enough to solve the problem
statement number 2 gives me another
point and then at this point if you're
really you know taking the GMAT and time
matters you just say hey I got two
points for this line two points is
everything I need to know about a line
once I know two points online I can
figure out if any other point is on that
line I'm done both statements combined
are sufficient you wouldn't have to do
all of this stuff that I did which would
waste your time but if you just to prove
to you that you could figure it out I
did that but anyway
I have to admit I did waste your time a
little bit you should just immediately
say oh I got two points on the line once
I have two points it's I can completely
figure out if I can if I if any other
point lies on that line
86 the length of the edging that
surrounds circular garden kay is okay so
we have two Gardens it looks like so we
have circular garden kay and then we
have circular garden let's see what does
it say is 1/2 the length of the edge
that's around circular garden G so this
is circular garden G this is K this is G
so they're saying the length of the
edging that's around circular garden K
is 1/2 the length of the edging that
surrounds circular garden G so we could
say circumference of K right that's the
edging that surrounds it is equal to 1/2
the circumference of G fair enough what
is the area of garden K assume that the
edging has negligible width well a
couple of things if we know the
circumference we know the area right
because the circumference is 2 PI R and
once we know our area is PI R squared so
if we can figure out the circumference
of of K then we know its area and if
what likewise if we know anything about
the radius or the diameter or the area
of C of G we can figure out a
circumference if we know its area we can
use a formula area equals PI R squared
right PI R squared to figure out what R
is and then once you figure out R is you
could figure out that circumference is
equal to 2 PI R so if you have any of
this information you're able to figure
out any of the rest of it so statement
number one says the area of G is equal
to 25 PI square meters so let me write
it area of G is equal to 25 pi so
immediately should say hey if I know the
area of G I can figure out the radius of
G and if I know the radius of G I can
figure out the circumference of G if I
know the circumference of G I can figure
out the circumference of K if I know the
circumference of can figure out the
radius of K and if I know the radius of
K I know
area of K you shouldn't have to
calculate any of that so this is enough
this is sufficient statement to and
maybe I'll do that for you just to show
you that it can be done but I hopefully
making is making some sense the edging
around G is 10 PI meters long so they're
actually giving us there's telling us
that the circumference of G is equal to
10 pi so this is even easier they're
giving us this that means the
circumference of K is 5 pi which means
that we can figure out the radius of of
K and we could figure out the area so
this is also sufficient to solve the
problem and just so you know you don't
take a word for let me just show you how
quickly you could figure it out if the
area of G is 25 pi that means that pi
times the radius squared of G is equal
to 25 pi that means that the radius is
equal to 5 right cancel out the PI on
both side R squared equal to 5
these are radius is 5 that means the
circumference is 2 pi times this so that
means that the circumference of G is
equal to 2 pi times 5 which is 10 PI
which is exactly what statement 2 told
us and then from there we could forget
the circumference of K which is half of
that so circumference of K is equal to 5
pi and then we know that 2 pi times the
radius of K is equal to 5 pi divided
both sides by pi we know that the radius
is equal to 5 halves and then the area
of K would be pi times this squared so
it would be pi times 25 over 4 and we'd
be done but all of this is a waste of
time I just wanted to show you that you
once you have the radius or the
circumference or the area of either of
these you're able to figure out
everything else and I'm out of time see
in the next video